so we Travolta's were huge Sophia and
fans we were definitely first in line to
see houseboat a great family movie I was
very young then but some years later
when I was old enough to appreciate
other amazing aspects of this beautiful
lady I came face to screen with Sophia
Loren and yesterday today and tomorrow
and like my daughter says when she
Twitter's o-m-g oh my god I came out of
the theater vibrating from the waist
down I got chills and they were
definitely multiplying there were
several great female superstars of that
era the sensuous Marilyn the elegant Liz
the seductive Bardot but Sophia Loren
embodies them all in Italy where I grew
up in the city of Rome
I remember seeing Sophia in the
magazines we had in our home from her
first photo shoot in jeans was it Joey
yeah Grazia it's a paparazzi defy
walking down Via Condotti tall smiling
and proud not only was she an actress
who stood up for what she believes she
stood for everyone she was a column of
strength and full of grace for all of us
to see her beauty her fashion it was
every Italians dream
her name is synonymous with Italy you
hear her name and a smile of love with
Atos comes from every one towards her
when my mother was 16 years old she and
her mother left their tiny village near
Naples and went to Rome they were off to
track down my mother's father and
convinced him to come back home but
Sophia also had another idea she dreamed
of trying her hand at show business
after a few weeks in Rome two things
became quite clear my mother's father
had no intention of playing the role of
a husband or father to his family and
the Italian film industry had no
intention of hiring my mother
when the two women ran out of money they
had no choice but to return home however
on the day of departure as my
grandmother stepped onto the train back
to Naples she turned to see my mother
standing on the platform motionless
Sophia refused to leave she was sixteen
passionate about film and she knew that
returning to Naples meant the end of her
dreams
my grandmother had only minutes to
convince her daughter to board the train
as it was about to leave but no
arguments wait my mother's resolved to
stay in Rome and pursue her passion my
grandmother saw the determination in the
eyes of her sixteen year old child and
made the split-second choice to
sacrifice her own destiny for the dreams
of her daughter they remained in Rome
and the rest is history
gosh when I met Sophia it's so great to
see you by the way looking so beautiful
I met her it was like I was it was like
a film it was like I was in a film
because we were rehearsing over at a
sound stage here in Hollywood and we
knew she was coming I had cast her in
the film of nine but I hadn't met her
yet and we heard she was outside of
course I was about to have a heart
attack my heart was beating a mile a
minute and came and she came through the
door and I saw that silhouette that
amazing silhouette and then she stepped
literally into the light and there she
was I mean those beautiful cat-like eyes
that those amazing cheekbones that
beautiful nose those full lips I thought
God take me now this is it doesn't get
better than this because there was a day
we were shooting in Rome in the Piazza
del Popolo and she was in a little
Italian sports car and it was we were
you know it was in the 60th movie took
place in the 60s and there she was
and I thought how did this kid from
Pittsburgh get here to Rome to be able
to say action and cut with Sophia Loren
in a car and a little sports car I mean
for me it was beyond and she knows the
camera like no one she really does she's
a master and a genius actor I mean
that's the thing people must know I mean
you see it in this work I mean it's the
range is extraordinary
you